de plus en plus de femmes ou d'hommes
élèvent leurs enfants tout seuls à paris
et dans les hauts-de-seine c'est la
conclusion d'une étude très fouillée de
l'insee sur ce qu'on désigne d'un terme
un petit peu barbare les familles
monoparentales l'étude porte sur les
vingt dernières années et l'on
s'aperçoive dans la capitale une famille
sur quatre ne compte qu'un seul enfant
philippe lafon familles monoparentales
définition il s'agit d'un parent sans
conjoints vivent avec un ou plusieurs
enfants de moins de 25 ans ont eux mêmes
célibataire sans conjoint ni enfant
portrait robot pour paris ile-de-france
à plus de 86%
ce sont des femmes avec enfants souvent
divorcées ou mères célibataires
selon les statistiques de l'insee tirées
du recensement de 1990 est la ville dans
les villes moyennes où les grandes
villes près de 17 % des familles sont
monoparentales en ile de france soit une
sur cinq
une sur quatre sur paris elle se loge le
plus souvent en habitat collectif
location hlm et travaille plutôt dans le
secteur tertiaire avec une
prédisposition pour le secteur public
1,6 et le nombre moyen d'enfants au
foyer chez les parents seuls contre 1,9
chez les couples
enfin ce type de famille a augmenté de
63% en 20 ans essentiellement en
fonction de la recrudescence des
divorces et du développement de l'union
libre